وفي لبنان ايضا مشاهدينا احتجاجات متزامنه
ومتشابهه شكلا ومضمونا يشهدها الشارعان
اللبناني والعراق عمله محليه متدهوره
وغلاء بالاسعار حيث تجمع العراقيون اليوم
امام البنك المركزي للاحتجاج ضد انخفاض
الدينار العراقي مقابل الدولار تراجع
الدينار اطاح سريعا بمحافظه المركزي اما
سبب ما وصف بجنون الدولار فهو تهريب
الدولارات من العراق الى ايران والمقدره
بنحو مئه مليون دولار شهريا حسب رويترز
علما بان تراجع قيمه الدينار امام
الدولارتها عند
160 دينارا للدولار الواحد وهو رقم لم
يسجله العراق منذ 19 عاما المشهد في لبنان
مشاهدينا لم يختلف كثيرا حيث احتج العشرات
امام البنك المركزي على خلفيه تردد
الاوضاع المعيشيه وارتفاع اسعار المحروقات
حرق اطارات واغلاق طرقات اساسيه في مناطق
مختلفه وسط انت المكثف للجيش فالليره
اللبنانيه تواصل انهيارها امام الدولار
الغير المسبوق ملامسه عتبه عتبه 56,000
ليره مقابل الدولار في السوق السوداء هذا
هو اغلقت محطات البنزين ابوابها على ان
تعاود عملها بعد صدور جدول جديد للاسعار
من وزاره الطاقه